Very curious,
discoveries in radiation
changed the world.
She became one of the most important
women in science and research is still
important to scientists and doctors today.
She'd be having the first person,
male or female,
to win the Nobel prize twice.
And Marie's discovery of the element
radium helps unlock the mysteries of the
asam.
Yet she came from the most
unlikely of circumstances.
Marie Curie showed us that through
hard work and determination,
anything is possible.
So in this week's biographics
where you meet Marie Curie,
scientific pioneer,
it was like a new world opened up to me,
the world of science,
Maria Salamis split.
Oscar was born on November the seventh,
18,
67 in Warsaw opponents.
She was the fifth child bones or
you've let us love and Brenna slower
[inaudible] who were both teachers
Vladislav toward high school physics and
mathematics.
And although bronner slower,
I gave birth to five children in
eight years and had tuberculosis.
She was the full time director
of a private school for girls.
It was only after the birth of Maria
that she finally retired through a series
of bad investments.
The family had unfortunately
lost their savings,
requiring them to board at the private
school where bronner slower had taught.
This,
meant that for the children there was no
privacy and they had to keep quiet and
on their best behavior at all
times as it has mentioned,
bronislaw slower suffered
from tuberculosis.
She was terrified of passing the lung
disease onto her children so she refused
to hug them or show
any physical affection.
When Maria,
who was known as Monia,
was around five,
the family managed to get a place of their
own that they had to take in boarders
in order to make ends meet manual.
Didn't have her own bedroom,
but had to sleep on the sofa in the
dining room as part of her chores.
She had to get up early in order
to set the table for breakfast.
Menu was fascinated with the
instruments that are father,
who was a teacher of physics captain.
His little study,
especially the electroscope when
she started school in Eighteen,
74,
age six.
She was the youngest and
the smallest child there.
However,
she proved herself to the among the
smartest of the students in her class.
She has an excellent memory,
so she was often selected to
recite poetry for visitors.
This was something that the intensely
shy girl absolutely detested life in
Poland.
It was tough during the latter
half of the 19th century.
Warsaw was under Russian.
Rule law forbids the speaking of Polish
or the learning of any Polish history.
However,
these laws totally backfired,
causing many polls,
including manuals,
family to be even more proud
of that Polish heritage.
Manny had dreamed of doing great things
and bringing honor to their country when
Monica was just eight
years old or older sisters.
Sophia caught typhus and died
about two years later and manuals.
Mother,
she died from tuberculosis.
That is all girl was inconsolable.
The two dearest people in her life,
her sister and her mother had been
cruelly snatched away from her.
Despite her despair manual was able to
maintain top grades at school with the
love and support her father
and remaining siblings.
She began to dream about
an accomplished future.
In 1883,
she completed a high school education.
She was the first in her class
in every single subjects.
Shortly thereafter though,
she became ill with what was
called fatigue of growth and study.
She spent a year recovering
with relatives in the country.
On her return,
Anya was intends on furthering
her education in the sciences,
but the Russian government's forbid
any Polish wound from attending the
University of Warsaw Year made
a pact with her older sister.
They would pull their finances so that
first and then Munya could attend the
University of Paris Manya spend
the next six years as governor,
which means that she was this more than
a seven to a wealthy family for three
and a half of those years.
She lived with us around risky families,
60 miles from Warsaw.
She tutored the children seven hours a
day and wasn't the Beck and call of the
remainder of the family at all
times with the father's approval.
She also taught to local peasant children
to read and write and illegal activity
for which she could have
been severely punished.
She used every moment of our
precious free time in order to study.
During this time,
manual also began attending
secret meetings of the
floating university members
read about scientific and other works
that were bounded by the Russians because
they thought that they might
stir up rebellious ideas.
After a year of living with this family,
my oldest son,
he was home from university.
He ends Manya now age 19,
quickly fell in love,
however,
around skis,
refused to let their son
marry a poor governess.
The unhappy couples separated but money.
I kept working for the family because
Bronwyn was depending on her in order to
pay her way to get over the heartbreak,
threw herself into her studies.
She focused on physics
and chemistry in 18,
99 employments with skis and this,
and she moved back to Warsaw where
she began working for another family.
One of her cousins ran Warsaw's
Museum of Industry and agriculture,
which was a lab with punish students,
including Manya,
could study science.
By 18,
91.
Marie had saved enough money for her to
join Bron in Paris and it was here that
she actually changed the name to Maria,
the French fashion off her name,
living with Ron owns a new husband's.
Murray attended these civilian university
before long she tired of the commute,
isn't moved into the student area and
living in a tiny attic with no proper
lighting and only a coal stove.
She had very little money,
ate poorly,
and sat to pay for our lessons and work
long hours in the university library to
do so.
Yet she founds a work so satisfying
that the hardships were worth.
It's a hot marie,
had to work much harder than
her classmates due to her
limited understanding of
the French language.
Still,
she graduated in 1893 having earned
a master's degree in physics.
She also got to the
top marks in her class.
In addition,
she won a scholarship which allowed her
to begin studying for a second degree
this time in mathematics
while studying for mathematics degree,
married,
got a job at studying the magnetism
of various types of steel for a French
company to do the work.
However,
she needed to find a lab,
a friend introduced it to a
man who could help it do so.
His name was Pierre Curie.
A teacher ran the head of the lab at
the School of industrial physics and
chemistry in Paris.
He was already famous at this point for
his work with crystals and magnets or
anything on doing our investigations
on the different types of steel.
This continued researching the
effect of electricity on crystals.
No one was more surprised
than carry herself when he
became attracted to Murray.
This man of science considered
most women to be a waste of space.
Yet Marie,
she was different.
She was brilliant and had
a deep love for science.
Instead of wooing her with flowers
per attempted to steal Marie's hot,
like giving her an autographed
copy of one of his physics papers,
asked Maria to marry him shortly after
they met Marie wanted to say yes,
but felt that if she did marry,
she would never again live
in her beloved Poland.
After completing her mathematics degree,
she returned to Warsaw for a holiday.
I'm sure if she would
have to go back to Paris.
However,
she was bombarded with
love letters from piano.
She finally decided to return in order
to continue her education and to see
Maria went married on July the 26th,
18,
95,
the ever practical Marie or a dark blue
suit that she could later were in the
lab for the next year.
She worked in studying steel
magnetism in August 18,
96.
She gave birth to Irene,
that first child becoming a mother.
Though it didn't slow her down,
she decided to earn a doctorate in
physics and needed a new topic to study.
She had heard about a French
physicist named Henri background,
Raul and his discovery of
mysterious uranium raise in 1896.
The subjects fascinated turn.
She decided to make it
the focus of a doctorate
in November 18,
93.
Wilhelm and a German physicist discovered
it invisible penetrating rays coming
from an electric tube.
In one of his experiments,
he called the Max rates because we
just didn't know what they were.
They had the ability to pass
through flesh and other substances,
but not through hard dense materials
like bones and thick metals.
X Rays and their effects became
world famous within months in 18,
96,
the French physicist on Rebif [inaudible]
discovered more kinds of penetrating
race,
unlike Rincon,
which were made by an electrical effects.
These reviews that seem to come naturally
for the use of uranium that had left
the uranium lying on a sealed packet of
photographic paper for several days in a
drawer,
and it caused the paper to miss over.
The uranium seemed to produce some
kind of invisible rays that could pass
through the thick black paper.
Most scientists,
they ignored the uranium raise,
but not Marie Curie.
She threw herself into the study first,
systematically searching for uranium
type of rays coming from other elements,
checking through all 70 elements.
She found that thorium gave off raise.
Next Marie analyzed rocks that contain
more than one elements as she expected.
Most of the uranium type raised given
off by the rocks called pitch blend.
This was because they contain
to uranium or thorium,
but surprise pitch blend gave off
more radiation than she expected,
and the question then came to mind,
well,
what was causing this extra radiation?
Also tracking our results
more than 20 times.
Maria announced in July of [inaudible]
98 that she had found a new elements.
She names it Polonia laughter,
her beloved Poland.
At the same time,
she invented the word radioactive to
describe a polonium uranium and thorium.
Then in December of 18,
98,
Maria announced the discovery of another
new and even more radioactive elements
radium,
but this was just the beginning because
years of work layer hat Marie and Pierre
had has approved to fellow scientists
that polonium and radium existed,
and to do this,
that to produce the two
elements in their purest forms,
find the weight of the atoms and show
that each element has an atomic weight
different from any other elements,
but their first focus.
It was to produce pure radiant.
To do this,
they needed a two things,
lots of pitch blends,
and to a large lab.
The pitch blends came from a mine in
Australia and securities were able to buy
it out very cheaply.
Finding lab space though that was harder.
The only room available was a
Kohl's leaky shed and the ops work,
but it gave them the
source that they needed.
Maria had some sales pitch Blanton's in
huge parts and stereo with a steel rod
almost as tall as he was.
Despite the hard work,
she was determined to discover everything
she could about radioactivity between
1,919 Oh,
three and Marie published many papers
on her work during this period.
She was also completing her doctoral
degree in trying to produce pure radium as
if that was not enough.
In 1900.
She began teaching at a teacher's
college in Sephora represents suburb,
and of course she was raising her
daughter Irene on July the 21st 19.
Oh,
two Marie finally reported the
weight of one radium assonance.
This was a major breakthrough because
of the weight of the radium atom was
different from the atomic
weight of any other elements.
It proved that Marie had indeed
discovered a new element.
Marie and Pierre could have become rich
by claiming all rights to working with
radium.
Instead,
they shared their information,
telling people how they purified
the elements and much more.
They believed scientific research
should benefit everybody.
In Nineteen,
oh,
three,
Maria became the first woman in Europe
to receive a doctorate in science,
but as the fame of the
Uber Science coupled group,
their physical health
began to deteriorate.
PA was constantly tired and in pain,
and Maria was also in a
constant state of exhaustion.
She had recently had a miscarriage
and had lost a lot of weight.
They both also suffered from burns,
numb fingertips.
We now know that they were suffering
from the effects of radiation exposure at
the time radium was being touted for its
health benefits because it could kill
healthy tissue.
Doctors tested it on disease cells
and found that it also destroyed them.
Soon.
Radium was being used to stop cancer cells
from growing in patients with cancer.
The new treatments,
it was called Curie
therapy in November 19.
Oh,
three marine pr.
We're given the Humphry Davy metal
England's highest award in chemistry,
but the greatest accolade that
came a month later when they,
along with Henri Becquerel,
won the Nobel Prize for physics.
The Nobel prize came with
a substantial cash award.
This allowed the curious for the
first time to hire a lab assistants.
Now reporters and visitors,
they wanted to meet the
famous scientific couple.
Some eager report has even attempted
to interview the curious young daughter
Irene Nobel prize winners have to travel
to Sweden to receive their reward and
speak about their work,
but Marie was too ill to go.
It wasn't until 1995 that she
was able to make the trip.
The couple's feelings about the prize,
though they wouldn't.
Next Marie was proud of our work and
Tara accomplishments of being the first
woman to achieve world
fame as a scientist.
The prize money also helps
to fund their research,
which they had so far been paying
for out of their own pockets,
but they disliked the theme that came
along with the award feeling that it
interfered with our work.
Then in 1984,
Marie gave birth to her
second daughter Eve.
Shortly thereafter,
pro has made a professor at the Sorbonne
and he was given about a laboratory.
Ends.
Marie was paid as his chief assistance.
The next year he was elected
to the Academy of Sciences.
For two years.
Things went well for the calories.
They were finally comfortable financially
and were respected leaders in their
field.
Then in April of Nineteen,
oh,
six tragedy struck there,
just enjoyed a relaxed weekend in the
country and we're back in rainy Paris.
A rushed off his feet per was
running errands in the rain.
When he stepped down to cross the road
and fell in front of a horse drawn wagon,
the sort of horse reared
up and it's he was missed,
but the rear wheels crushed his skull,
killing him instantly.
When word spread that a famous
scientist had been killed,
the crowd had to be stopped from
attacking the innocent driver.
Marie didn't tear about the tragedy
until she returned time that night.
She was simply devastated
by her husband's death.
However,
she remembers what he had once told her.
Whatever happens,
even if one should become
like a body without a soul,
still one must work,
so when she was offered her
husband's job at the Sorbonne,
she accepts it before her
first class reporters,
students and curious people crowded the
whole to see the first female teacher at
the institution.
They wondered if she would praise the
husbands or break down under the strain.
Instead,
she began quietly speaking,
picking up at the very spot where peer
had left off during his last lecture.
One of Marie's deepest regrets was the
peer who died without ever having his own
permanent lab.
It gave a great satisfaction in 1989
when plans were put in place to establish
the radium adds to use in Paris.
It would have a laboratory that Maria
would supervise and it would be known as
the Curie pavilion
working as hard as ever
Merinos did the Lord Calvin,
they Scottish physicists,
had suggested that radium was not an
elements since it had been found to give
off helium gas,
which is itself an elements.
She continued to make even purer
polonium and radium by 1910.
She had produced pure radium and show to
the attic was a brilliant white metal.
She even found its melting point,
which was 700 degrees Celsius in 1910.
Marie also published on 971 page work
treatise on radioactivity and in 1911,
Kim and other great honor,
the Nobel Prize for chemistry,
which was awarded to her
alone for making pure radium.
In Nineteen Eleven Radiology,
Congress and International Group of
radiation scientists decided they needed a
new unit of measurement for radiation
and they called it the curie.
Maria insisted that she was the only one
who could take on the task of working
out to the exact size of a curie eunice.
It was painstaking work,
but she did it all mps on it.
In 1911,
Marie found to be elected to
the French Academy of Sciences.
Many people said that it was
simply because she was a woman,
a scientific work.
It was the highest quality by this point.
Our personal life was being followed
closely by the newspapers and it was great
interest in her friendship with physicist,
colleague Paul longer vault,
extremely upset by all this attention
where you fell ill often treatment she
stayed with our friends have
gotten in England by 1914.
The radium institute at the University
of Paris was finished the same year that
weld wall one began.
Murray threw herself into the war effort.
She organized extra equipment
for hospitals to help them
locate bullets and trap
null in the wounds of injured soldiers.
She also set up a course to train
people in the use of radiography units.
Other wars ends.
In 1918,
Maria became director of
the Paris radium institutes.
The institutes became a World Center
for radiation physics and chemistry.
In 1920,
murray became friends with Marie
Maloney and American journalist.
Let me helps to improve curious public
image and plan to raise money for the
radium institute by a
lecture tour in the USA.
Although our hearing and
sight we're failing her,
she carried out part of the tour
before her illness for starter,
retired to France.
Many university is awarded
a special degrees and the
women of America gave her a
one gram of radium worth 100,000 dollars.
This was in recognition of our work and
achievements as a female scientist in
1922,
she was last elected to the
French Academy of Medicine.
In the Early Nineteen Twenty 20th,
scientists finally realized
the dangers of radiation.
People working with radioactive
material began taking precautions,
but it was too late for Marie.
How work with radiation probably caused
the cataract in our eyes that now
threatens out with blindness.
She had to have four operations
to remove the cataracts,
but wanted no one to know.
She didn't want people thinking
she was old and helpless.
Marie continued to oversee the
work in their own labs in Paris.
She also traveled to raise funds
for research by younger scientists.
In 1928,
she had a final operation for a cataract.
She was then cared for
by her daughter Eve.
After further illness,
she died on July the fourth,
19,
34 in Switzerland.
She died of a plastic anemia.
The lack of red blood cells caused by
extended exposure to radiation where his
legacy lived on in her
daughter Irene in 1935,
her husband Frederic received the
Nobel Prize for chemistry in 1995.
Marie and Pierre were reburied
in the Pantheon in Paris.
She is the first woman given that
honor based on her own achievements.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you can do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
wouldn't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.